We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. today
I have a voicemail from a psychiatric nurse
who claims claims to know what it is that
happened to Donald Trump relating to that
unexpected hospital visit a couple of weeks
ago.
Let's take a listen to her perspective.
Hi David, this is Catherine retired psychiatric
nurse.
I've called you a few times.
Um, I think probably what happened to Trump
when it went to the hospital is that he fell
because at his latest rally in Florida and
he has a new care piece and it's covering
what looks like his right cheek.
Um, a little bit too much.
Like the hair's too thick and the cheek looks
swollen.
I mean, he always looks swollen, but if I
don't, I'm looking from my phone.
I don't have it on the big screen, so maybe
it's not.
So, but that's just my impression.
Yeah.
This is actually really interesting because
number one, nobody even speculated about a
fall.
But interestingly, Donald Trump recently getting
off of the lower stairs off of air force one
several times and we said, well, that could
be, if there's concern about him falling sometimes
accompanied side by side by someone deplaning
with him when he comes off the big stairs
recently, the idea being there's someone there
to sort of keep them up against the side of
the stairs again to prevent falling.
I went back and looked at the rally that is
mentioned here.
And it is true that Trump, I mean listen,
I guess he denies wearing a toupee.
If you believe that he wears one, there was
a puff of hair on his left cheek.
I think she says the right it is the right
side.
If you're watching the rally with Trump facing
you, but it's Trump's left, there is a puff
of hair there again, it could just be windblown.
I don't really know.
And and again it does sort of seem like the
left cheek area is kind of swollen.
So this is the first I've heard of it.
Found it interesting that a viewer noticed
this.
I can tell you only to go back and look at
the Florida rally footage yourself and make
of it what you will.
We have such a great bonus show for you today.
I'm going to tell you some Thanksgiving stories.
Number one.
Uh, I will also tell you about a sort of social
experiment that I ran with the black Friday
membership special.
I'm not going to say anymore.
I think you will find this really, really
interesting.
And um, I hope that you will sign up either@joinpacmandotcomorbybecomingapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show.
I think you will find today's social experiment
that I reveal on the bonus show.
Very, very interesting and compelling.
I'll speak to you then or otherwise, tomorrow.
And yes, we will be live streaming Wednesdays,
impeachment inquiry hearings
on at least YouTube, if not YouTube and Twitch
more in that on tomorrow's [inaudible], the
David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.